Hey Youtubers, it's Charlie.
This is going to be my flash episode 11 video
full on vibe vs Gypsy.
So just careful for spoilers if you haven't
seen the episode yet we gotta talk about Wally
and Barry versus savitar earth 19 teasers
for the flash of that earth so much stuff,
but there is a new round of the flash ring
giveaway.
All you have to do to enters be a subscriber
and leave a comment about the episode on this
video be sure to click that bell to enable
alerts so that you don't miss anything.
So let's do top 10 and comic book Easter eggs
number 10 the intro to the electric gang with
Harrison wells narrating his novel I love
that he keeps trying to sell people on this
even when Gypsy had up later in the episode
during the trial by combat.
He was trying to sell her on it while they
were waiting for the battle to start the big
thing with him in this episode is all about
doing something that matters that was kind
of the theme across the entire episode for
all the characters making sure that their
life had meeting in that's why HR came to
this earth.
So number nine that led Gypsy to come after
him as a collector.
So we get all this.
Loren Backstory on earth.
19 hopefully will get to see it, really soon
because she let us know that she's not surprised
by speedsters.
She's able to cut them off from the speed
force using her vibe powers so that means
that Cisco can do it to but because is not
as good.
He hasn't learned about all those things yet
the reason she explains that she came for
HR is because he broke their most sacred law
interdimensional travel because 25 years ago
and their history another earth invaded there's
in they set up his travel ban she's part of
the task force the tracks those people doubt
that break the law and it basically a death
sentence and now she has to say that he's
dead.
So he can never go home, but number eight.
You can kind of see what they're setting up
for HR's character so they have that Lego
set of viruses dead and they know that they
see HR in the future.
On the rooftop with that gun the like do we
send them back to we stop him from going back
we know that HR is destined to show up.
Like Cisco said at the end of the episode,
so what I think that they might be doing is
setting us up to really care for HR because
it's kind of a douche bag your definitely
made to hate him when he first shows up he
is so annoying.
So by the end of the season I think the idea
is to make you love him for him to do something
that gives his life.
Meaning and an ongoing the rug right out from
under us kill him in a bowel with savitar
or someone else and that'll give Tom Cavanagh
a reason to play another character in season
four.
I just don't think that HR is going to be
here next season so there has to be a reason
for him to go away and he can't go back to
earth.
19 now.
So right now he's at the top of the list of
people who might die the end of the season
because I think we can all agree that Iris
is probably not can a dive will find a way
to save her, and it has to do with Wally number
seven Barry and Wally teaming up and showing
off.
New flash powers to take down the electric
gang at the beginning of the episode, so these
are like vibrate around each other.
So the guns can get a lock on them take them
down they'll be doing more of that because
they tease that Barry is going to be training
at the end of the episode to get faster and
faster the whole idea is that he's getting
way faster in a much faster rate that will
be fast enough to help Barry save Iris from
savitar because so far varies been thinking
about this in a very singular way.
I have to be fast enough to save Iris, but
now we have to flashes and that doesn't even
include Jay Garrick or Jesse quick or any
of the other speedsters of the multi-verse
Barry had the speech in the episode where
he talked to Cisco about getting through the
tough times he's as I lean on you guys.
You guys keep me going in the dark times.
So he just learning to rely on the rest of
team flash now he's going to rely on Wally
to help him out with his savitar problem and
really nice small Ville Easter egg you guys
may have noticed the cheerleaders that Wally
rescued that he was taken all the selfies
with look exactly like the cheerleaders from
small Ville such as a whole bunch of Wally
stuff they're building out in the back half
of the season there's rumors that he might
just store on legends of tomorrow, but what
I'm really hoping is is they tease some of
the powers that Wally develops that Barry
does not have every member of the flash family
learns to use the speed force in slightly
different ways.
So they have slightly different abilities
one of the big ones, he develops in the comics
is sort of like Superman's Sunburst ability
just a giant burst of electrical speed force
energy, so number six the other big thing
hereto that I love is the Julian is on the
team.
He's like this cold mathematician was like
the get shit done person so that they're trying
to figure this played out.
He's like look let's is mathematics you need
to get this fast by this time or else your
knocking to be able to save her, he's the
one that had the idea to create the Lego set
he's also striving for meaning.
There's so much left for his character.
The season.
I feel like he still tied to the philosopher's
stone there has to be a reason for savitar
to come back to our earth with his number
ways that could go down.
I have a feeling you'll have something to
do with Dr. alchemy.
So right now Julie is just doing what everyone
else is trying to do make his life have meaning
learn to be on the team, but he's one of the
new guys we just of pipes up at the really
awkward moments really funny responses like
oh well.
She must've been having an off day otherwise.
Cisco would totally died number five is Iris
distracting joke by teasing the tornado twins
in the comics she and Barry have two children
there twins they themselves have speed powers,
but their son Don Allen has a son named Bart
Allen.
So he's the one that comes back from the future
to fight with team flash during the Mark Wade
era.
The comics that's when Wally West was the
main version of the flash but she takes it
right back in an instant says.
Do you think that Barry is a dog person or
Person.
So was like a really brief tease that they
might have children in the future, so who
knows if will ever do that on the TV show
I'm assuming.
Not because if we do see their children if
we did see Bart Allen on the show.
It would probably be in a flash forward or
like in the comics.
Bart would show up from the future and present
day and they would really know where he came
from Tillie explained himself but I totally
loved Iris and Wally teaming up brother sister
crime-fighting team just like during flash
point.
Hopefully they'll do that again during the
season.
They have a nice energy together so there
scenes were a lot of fun.
But that whole Iris storyline was really just
to set up that payoff at the end were she's
telling Barry how she's worried that she's
going to be like her mother should just go
away and she won't have left any kind of mark,
so Barry has to calm her down, so was a great
payoff.
It was a great moment but you know most of
those Iris scenes felt a little out of pace
with the Cisco versus Gypsy storyline, but
it's all about doing something meaningful
with your life.
So there's thematic consistency across the
episode number four was Cisco's challenge
to Gypsy trial by combat very timely game
of thrones reference mixed with the Lord of
the rings reference come and claim him.
So he was just throwing them left and right
in the funny thing is is that he learned the
Gypsy also has her own references to all spinal
tap that.
But as she's sucking him through the portal
to the other Earth's but the training montage
was great the whole energy with all the characters
was so much better in this episode.
Cisco wasn't all mopey Julian was funny he
had really nice comedic timing with Caitlin
work on your interpersonal skills, so the
energy in the group is so much better in the
back half of the season I'm so much happier
with what's going on now number three was
vibe versus Gypsy multi-verse battle.
So there were three different nurse that they
went to the
first one they went to was earth two Cisco
recognizes these like holy crap, this is earth
two that kind of teased up that were going
to be seeing Earth to again really quickly
with the gorilla city episode that's two-part.
So will see Jesse quick again real soon.
The next or they go to is Supergirl's earth,
earth 38 the ring Grants office you see Ms.
test mocker like oh my God.
Somebody call Supergirl she must be off helping
somebody else in this last planet looks like
something right out of Star Wars like it's
most of far Anakin versus Obi-Wan next to
the llama and almost completely forgot to
mention we gotta talk about Cisco in the full
vibe costume for the first time in present
day and he refers to himself as vibe for the
very first time you can call me vibe or Cisco
or anything else Gypsy was just so much fun
in this episode.
So hands down Gypsy is one of my favorite
new characters.
You can definitely expect her to come back
sometime maybe even before the end of the
season.
Just in the way that they left things number
two is action.
The mystery speedster from earth.
19 that she tease like oh you're a speedster
like she's totally seen a bunch before that's
the accelerated man that everybody's been
asking about for the past couple of months
so I think the idea is that we'll see him
sometime in the next couple weeks want to
wait too long, but the flash is going on break
after next week's episode, so that the two-part
gorilla city episode won't be for three weeks
instead of just two weeks.
So is gonna be a while but we'll see them
pretty soon.
He actually came from the most diversity grant
Morrison comic, so he does have like a really
big Backstory.
So the TV show is free to do whatever they
want to with them, but a lot of people were
wondering if it might be Eddie Thawne because
he just showed up behind the scene, but the
episode there filming with him is like episode
18.
So it's not anywhere near the gorilla city
episode whatever Eddie's doing he's probably
not going to be the accelerated man.
Although would be cool for him to be a speedster
in the future season.
The number one thing of course is Barry teasing
that Wally is the key to defeating savitar
there's a number of different ways they could
take this because comic book Ginger Wally
in the comics eventually became the fastest
version of the flash.
He even has white lightning in the rebirth
comics right now like savitar has, so they
could take it that direction, but because
Barry is always here in this moment.
I feel like it will be a two on one thing
where he distracts savitar and Wally runs
in to save Iris is supposed to Barry running
up and snatching her out of his claws because
the problem with making Wally faster than
savitar is that the show would be over if
Wally became that powerful if Barry became
that powerful than their be nobody to challenge
them there be no drama anymore, so whatever
the solution to defeating savitar, is this
season there still a couple ways to defeat
him, it won't leave them being all powerful.
So even though eventually Barry will probably
join the speed force become the God of speed
himself that's like the distant future of
the show you can let me know in the comments
how do you think that Barry is going to use
Wally to help save Iris if you like it's going
to be you know him distracting savitar while
Wally runs into snatcher there still number
ways they could do that.
So like I said there's a new episode next
week the week after that the flash goes on
break.
So just remind people as I post new bonus
videos what's can happen next is is I'll post
a trailer video for next week's episode that
I'll post legends of tomorrow Legion of doom,
so much reverse flash Backstory that they
told and make sure you watch arrow to because
that video will post Wednesday night they're
introducing a new version of the Black Canary
so they'll explain how that's gonna work.
So the really important episode.
I will say congratulations to Devion mcbreen
you're the new flash ring giveaway winner.
There's a new round that started in this video
I'll remind everyone when I post my trailer
video in the morning while you guys wait for
that to post you can click here to learn all
about the flash is greatest power and you
can click here to learn all about what's going
on with the Batman movie.
Thank you so much watching everybody let's
high five I'll see you in the next video!